gegen Amerika sein gegen die Weltpolizei
gegen krassen Kapitalismus das klingt
jetzt erstmal noch nicht nach
schwurbelei Antiamerikanismus ist in
Deutschland in verschiedener Ausprägung
sowohl in der politischen Rechten als
auch in der Linken verbreitet manche
behaupten aber sogar die USA haben
Deutschland komplett im Griff und
Steuern hier alles auch unter unserem
ersten backgroundcheck Video zur Frage
ob Deutschland ein besetztes Land ist
kamen solche Kommentare auf so mancher
Demo heißt es deswegen amig go home aber
was ist da wirklich ran auf der einen
Seite haben wir die Welt und Atommacht
USA die seit 1945 ihre Truppen in
Deutschland hat tausende US Soldatin und
Soldaten sind auf mehr als 20
Militärstützpunkten stationiert wie z.B
auf der Airbase in Rammstein auf der
anderen Seite steht Deutschland für
viele eher eine schwache Lachnummer
nicht erst seit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine wissen wir
unser Militär ist richtig mies
ausgerüstet und nicht mal die
regierungsflieger der Bundeswehr
funktionieren richtig das klingt nach
einem heftigen
machtungleichgewicht aber sind wir
militärisch wirklich komplett auf die
Amerikaner angewiesen wir schauen uns in
diesem Video mal genauer an was in den
airbases wie rabstein eigentlich vor
sich geht und checken wie abhängig
Deutschland wirklich von den USA
ist seit dem russischen Angriffskrieg
ist klar Europa und besonders die
Ukraine wärden richtig verloren ohne die
USA die mit Abstand die meisten Waffen
liefert
und ihr erinnert euch bestimmt an die
chaotischen Bilder vom Flughafen in
Kabul 2021 beim Abzug aus Afghanistan
wurde mehr als deutlich wie sehr die
Sicherheit der deutschen und anderen
europäischen Truppen von den Amerikanern
abhing Deutschland und Europa verlassen
sich auf Sicherheitsgarantien der USA
bzw auf die gemeinsame Stärke der NATO
sollte Deutschland je angegriffen werden
könnten wir uns ohne die Hilfe der USA
kaum verteidigen die Bundeswehr ist
schon länger in einem desaströsen
Zustand gegen Gensatz zu Deutschland
sind die USA eine der stärksten
Militärmächte der Welt nach Russland
haben Sie außerdem die zweitmeisten
Atomwaffen im Kriegsfall könnten sie
einem Gegner auch ohne ihre
natoverbündeten die Stirn bieten aber
vor allem um Ramstein ranken sich einige
Theorien die Airbase Ramstein sieht zwar
so aus als ob man in den USA wäre ist
aber deutsches Staatsgebiet und somit
gilt ja auch deutsches Recht an dass
sich die US Truppen zu halten haben die
Sache hat aber einen ziemlich großen
Haken durchgesetzt werden kann das Recht
nämlich de facto nicht ohne die
Zustimmung der Amerikaner dürfen
deutsche Behörden nicht mal da rein wir
haben uns für euch mal die krassesten
Thesen zu Ramstein rausgesucht und auf
ihren Wahrheitsgehalt gecheckt these
Nummer 1 in Ramstein haben die Deutschen
nichts zu sagen aber zahlen müssen Sie
dafür die Airbase ist die größte
Einrichtung der US-Luftwaffe außerhalb
der USA man könnte Ramstein auch little
America nennen denn hier leben ca 50.000
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner wie in
einer kleinen Stadt darunter natürlich
Soldatinnen und Soldaten aber auch
Mitarbeitende der Militärbasis und deren
Angehörige okay also wir dürfen nicht
rein aber zahlen müssen wir stimmt das
ja tatsächlich allein zwischen 2010 und
2020 hat Deutschland insgesamt fast eine
Milliarde Euro für die Stationierung der
US-Truppen ausgegeben das waren Kosten
für Baumaßnahmen und sogenannte
verteidigungsfolgekosten also z.B
beihilfezahlung an ehemalige
Beschäftigte des us-mitärs allerdings
ist das was Deutschland zahlt nur ein
Bruchteil von dem was die USA für ihre
hier stationierten Truppen ausgeben das
waren laut einer Schätzung allein für
das Jahr 2020 nämlich 7,2 Milliarden
Euro an thesee 1 ist also durchaus was
dran allerdings tragen die USA den
Löwenanteil der Kosten aber dass
Deutschland in Ramstein nicht viel zu
sagen hat hat halt auch Konsequenzen und
damit kommen wir schon zu these Nummer 2
die usstitkräfte nutzen Ramstein für
droh Angriffe auf der ganzen Welt
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch hieran
Anfang 2020 hatten die USA den Chef der
iranischen revolutionsgarten Kassim
Soleimani mit einem drohenangriff im
Irak getötet das hat eine internationale
Krise und teilweise sogar Panik vor
einem Dritten Weltkrieg ausgelöst und
jetzt kommt ohne die Airbase in Ramstein
wäre dieser umstrittene Angriff gar
nicht möglich gewesen denn das us-mitär
betreibt in Ramstein eine sogenannte
satellitenrelaisstation und die ist
entscheidend für die drohneneinsätze die
Piloten der Drohnen sitzen in den USA
und steuern sie von da aus das geht aber
nur dank der Anlagen in Ramstein die das
Signal der drohen per Satellit empfangen
verstärken und per Glasfaserkabel dann
in die USA weiterleiten außerdem
befindet sich in Ramstein eins von
weltweit fünf distributed ground Systems
kurz DGS das sind Kontrollzentren in
denen Livebilder der drohen ausgewertet
und mit nachrichtendienstlichen
Erkenntnissen abgeglichen werden das
heißt es kann z.B verif iziert werden
aber sich bei den von der Drohne
aufgespürten Personen um die gesuchten
Terroristen handelt vor 10 Jahren wurden
die Infos zur Rolle ramsteins bei
solchen drohenangriffen zum ersten Mal
öffentlich die verschiedenen
Bundesregierungen haben sich aber immer
wieder darauf berufen keine eigenen
Erkenntnisse darüber zu haben was die
US-Truppen da genau machen aber man
befinde sich stets im vertrauensvollen
Dialog mit den amerikanischen
Verbündeten das hat auch die aktuelle
Regierung 2022 auf kleine Anfragen der
AF und der Linksfraktion im Bundestag
geantwortet aber sind diese Angriffe
überhaupt mit deutschem Recht und dem
Völkerrecht vereinbar fangen wir mit dem
Völkerrecht an eine
sonderberichterstatterin der Vereinten
Nationen hatte den Angriff auf Soleimani
z.B als höchstwahrscheinlich
rechtswidrig im Sinne des Völkerrechts
bezeichnet die USA hatten als Grund für
den Angriff unmittelbare bevorstehende
Bedrohung für Amerikaner in der Region
angegeben die Rechtfertigung der USA
wurden aber von vielen Seiten z.B auch
dem wissen wienschaftlichen Dienst des
Deutschen Bundestages als nicht
ausreichend und der Einsatz damit als
völkerrechtswidrig eingeschätzt aber wie
sieht es mit der rechtlichen Lage in
Deutschland aus tatsächlich hatten
Abgeordnete der Linksfraktion im
Bundestag Mitglieder der damaligen
Bundesregierung wie z.B Kanzlerin Merkel
wegen Beihilfe durch Unterlassen zum
Mord angezeigt ein Ermittlungsverfahren
wurde aber nicht eingeleitet weil laut
Bundesanwaltschaft keine zureichenden
tatsächlichen Anhaltspunkte für ein
strafbares Verhalten der angezeigten
Personen vorliegen würde die warf der
Bundesanwaltschaft daraufhin unter
anderem eine verkürzte juristische
Sichtweise vor in Deutschland wurde aber
auch schon öfter wegen US
drohenangriffen ermittelt das ist in
letzter Instanz aber immer ohne
Konsequenzen geblieben zuletzt hat das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht im Jahr 2020
ein entscheidendes Urteil zu US
drohenangriffen im Jen gefällt darin
heißt es unter anderem die
Bundesregierung habe ihre Pflichten
erfüllt weil sie politische und
diplomatische Gespräche mit den USA
geführt haben auch zu rechtlichen Fragen
rund um die drohen Sätze außerdem fehlte
im Gericht der qualifizierte Bezug zum
deutschen Staatsgebiet der reine
Datenstrom durch Rammstein sei nicht
genug und ob Informationen zu den
entsprechenden Angriffen vor Ort
ausgewertet würden also ob Leute in
Rammstein saßen und gesagt haben wohin
geschossen werden soll konnte hier nicht
bewiesen werden fzit zur these Nummer 2
also die USA nutzen Rammstein
tatsächlich für drohenangriffe verstoßen
damit aber laut bisheriger
Rechtssprechung in Deutschland nicht
gegen geltendes Recht Deutschland ist
jur nicht verpflichtet mehr zu
unternehmen als bisher die umstrittenen
drohenangriffe sind aber ein Grund warum
z.B die Linksfraktion 2019 gefordert hat
die Airbase zu schließen und die
Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner vor die
Tür zu setzen rechtlich wäre das
übrigens möglich seit 1990 könnte
Deutschland die Verträge mit den
US-Truppen mit einer Frist von 2 Jahren
kündigen was aber z.B der
Wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages
in einem Sachstandsbericht von 2017 als
politisch nicht gangbaren Weg bezeichnet
hat aber warum eigentlich Deutschland
zahlt viel Geld für die US-Truppen kann
dort kein deutsches Recht durchsetzen
und muss akzeptieren dass die USA mit
Hilfe von Rammstein zumindest
umstrittene Angriffe fliegen und
Menschen töten haben die Amis uns also
wirklich in der Hand um das besser zu
verstehen müssen wir mal einen Blick in
die Vergangenheit und auf einige
wichtige Ereignisse in der
deutsch-amerikanischen Geschichte werfen
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg war
Deutschland natürlich extrem von den USA
abhängig 1945 hat Nazi deutschland
kapituliert und die Alliierten also
Großbritannien Frankreich die sowjetun
und eben die Amerikaner haben das Land
in vier Besatzungszonen aufgeteilt
Deutschland wurde von den Alliierten
regiert und war aus gutem Grund nicht
mehr eigenständig zwischen den
Besatzungsmächten kam es aber immer
wieder zu Konflikten Frankreich
Großbritannien und die USA auf der einen
und die Sowjetunion auf der anderen
Seite 1949 spitzte sich der Konflikt
dann so zu dass es schließlich zwei
deutsche Teilstaaten gab die BRD und die
DDR beide Staaten waren von anderen
abhängig aber ihr Verhältnis zu den USA
war natürlich sehr unterschiedlich im
Westteil des Landes wurde die USA
zunehmend als Schutzmacht gesehen für
den Osten war es der systemfeind und für
den Osten blieb das mit der Abhängigkeit
von der Sowjetunion auch bis zur
Wiedervereinigung so im Westen lief es
etwas anders 1954 wurden dort nämlich
die sogenannten Pariser Verträge
unterzeichnet durch sie ist
Westdeutschland 1955 der NATO und der
WEU also der westeuropäischen Union
beigetreten durch den natoeitritt bzw
dem dazugehörigen aufenthaltsvertrag
erlaubte Deutschland insgesamt acht
nataaten den dauerhaften Aufenthalt von
Truppen im Land darunter auch den USA
der Beitritt zu NATO hat aber noch mehr
folgen und zwar die sogenannte nukleare
Teilhabe das ist ein Konzept der NATO
bei dem Atommächte wie die USA andere
Staaten ohne Atomwaffen beschützen
sollen die USA können also Atomwaffen in
Deutschland lagern und das ist auch
heute noch so ca 20 Atombomben Lagern
wohl im Fliegerhorst Büchel der genau
wie Rammstein in Rheinland Falz liegt
deren Existenz will zwar niemand so ganz
iell bestätigen gilt aber als eine Art
offenes Geheimnis Deutschland ist auch
heute noch auf die USA und NATO
angewiesen was die Sicherheit angeht die
internationalen Truppen und sogar deren
Atomwaffen sollen der Sicherheit und
Abschreckung dienen für all das hat
Deutschland sich aber selbst entschieden
wir müssen h jetzt nämlich mal zwischen
Abhängigkeit und dem Dasein als
Marionette der USA unterscheiden von dem
manche sprechen mit den Pariser
Verträgen hat Deutschland sich nicht nur
für mehr Sicherheit entschieden sondern
bekam auch die fast vollständige
Souveränität zurück durch die Verträge
war Westdeutschland ab 1955 also nicht
mehr von den USA und den anderen
Alliierten besetzt das heißt man konnte
z.B wieder selbstständig über
diplomatische Beziehung verhandeln und
Botschaften einrichten mit dem 2+4
Vertrag erlangte das wiedervereinigte
Deutschland 1990 dann übrigens auch die
vollständige Souveränität zurück und
auch das Gebiet der ehemaligen DDR war
damit von der Sowjetunion unabhängig
wenn ihr noch mehr dazu wissen wollt
könnt ihr auch noch mal unser erstes
backgroundcheck Video schauen da haben
uns im Detail ang schaut ob Deutschland
noch ein besetztes Land ist und was es
mit einem Friedensvertrag auf sich hat
seit 1990 kann ganz Deutschland also
eigenständige Entscheidung treffen und
ist somit kein bloßer Erfüllungsgehilfe
und keine Marionette der USA und dass
das auch schon länger so war hat sich
schon mit den neuen Ostpolitik unter
Willi Brand gezeigt seine Annäherung an
den Osten ab 1969 war zunächst gar nicht
im Interesse der USA aber Brand hat sich
davon nicht beirren lassen oder auch
beim Irakkrieg 2003 hat Deutschland den
USA die gefolg verweigert und damit für
einige Unstimmigkeiten im
deutsch-amerikanischen Verhältnis
gesorgt natürlich ist Deutschland aber
nicht völlig unabhängig von den USA
nicht nur was unsere Sicherheit angeht
sondern auch unsere Wirtschaft
Deutschland lebt vor allem von Exporten
und die USA sind der größte
Handelspartner wenn es um Exporte geht
in entscheidenden Punkten hatten die USA
und Deutschland in der Vergangenheit
aber einfach oft deckungsgleiche bzw gut
miteinander zu vereinbarende Interessen
die USA brauchen Deutschland z.B als
Standort sie selbst sind von ihren
Einsätzen auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent oder im Mittleren Osten weit
entfernt deswegen ist Deutschland ein
guter Standort für ihre
Kommandozentralen und Deutschland
profitiert nach wie vor von den
Sicherheitsgarantien durch die NATO auch
wenn das hierzulande nicht unumstritten
ist sowohl die Friedensbewegung als auch
einige Parteien fordern den Abzug der
US-Atomwaffen aus Deutschland im
Angesicht der neuen Bedrohung aus
Russland spielt die Debatte darüber aber
gerade kaum noch eine Rolle im Gegenteil
fordern jetzt sogar Länder wie Polen bei
der nuklearen Teilhabe mitmach zu dürfen
dabei sind bisher nämlich nur fünf
natooländer Deutschland Italien
Niederlande Belgien und die Türkei zum
Abschluss wollen wir aber jetzt noch mal
einen Blick in die Zukunft wagen und
schauen wie sich das
deutsch-amerikanische Verhältnis
weiterentwickeln könnte sind die
Interessen von Deutschland und den USA
auch weiterhin gut miteinander vereinbar
hier kommen auf jeden Fall einige neue
Herausforderungen auf uns zu von 2016
bis 2021 war ja Donald Trump
US-Präsident was die Beziehung zwischen
Deutschland und den USA extrem belast
hat denn seine America first Politik
scherte sich wenig um europäische oder
deutsche Interessen Trump stellte sogar
die NATO zunehmend in Frage außerdem hat
er bereits geplant tausende ussldatinen
und Soldaten aus Deutschland abzuziehen
2021 ist mit Joe Biden aber wieder ein
sogenannter Transatlantiker ins Weiße
Haus eingezogen er hat z.B den geplanten
Truppenabzug aus Deutschland direkt
wieder gestoppt aber das bedeutet noch
lange nicht dass jetzt wieder alles wie
vor 2016 ist denn auch Joe Biden führt
die America first Politik Trumps in
vielerlei Hinsicht fort das wohergehen
Deutschland und Europas ist nicht mehr
Priorität der Amerikaner denn die USA
haben seit einiger Zeit ganz eigene
Probleme spätestens seit der Wahl Donald
Trumps ist das Land politisch gespalten
und produktive Zusammenarbeit zwischen
den beiden großen politischen Lagern den
Republikanern und den Demokraten wurde
immer schwieriger außenpolitisch sieht
die Lage nicht rosiger aus mit China
gibt's einen neuen geopolitischen
Konkurrenten auf der Weltbühne mit dem
sich die USA immer mehr beschäftigen
müssen auch wenn die USA jahrzehntelang
die Schutzmacht für Deutschland und
Europa waren gehen Fachleute davon aus
dass die USA ihren Schutz an immer mehr
Bedingungen knüpfen werden die USA
könnten Deutschland und Europa z.B vor
die Wahl stellen entweder aufzuhören mit
China Geschäfte zu machen oder wichtige
sicherheitszusagen der Amerikaner zu
verlieren deswegen fordern viele
Fachleute dass Deutschland und Europa
sich unabhängiger machen sollen z.B
indem sie mehr auf europäische
Verteidigungsbündnisse setzen das
leuchtet ein vor allem wenn man bedenkt
dass 2024 in den USA wieder gewählt wird
und die Wiederwahl Joe beidens alles
andere als sicher ist neben Ex-Präsident
Trump machen aber auch noch andere
republikanische Kandidaten wie der
Gouverneur von Florida Ron de santtis
von sich Reden der lässt unter anderem
mit seiner Haltung zum ukrainekrieg
erahnen wie sehr er sich um Europas
Interessen und Schutz bemühen würde für
ihn sei der Krieg bloß ein regionaler
Konflikt in den sich die USA nicht
weiter verwickeln lassen sollten wenn
man bedenkt dass die USA gerade die
meisten Waffen und die meiste
Unterstützung an die Ukraine liefern
wäre auch ein potenzieller US-Präsident
des Santes ganz schlechte Neuigkeiten
für Europa aber fassen wir noch mal kurz
zusammen Deutschlands und auch Europas
Sicherheit sind von den USA abhängig
Punkt das heißt aber nicht dass die Amis
hier nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg immer
noch die Fäden in der Hand halten Joe
Biden kann nicht einfach Kanzler Scholz
anrufen und diktieren was er zu tun hat
Deutschland kann eigene Entscheidung
treffen und tut es wie wir gesehen haben
auch Deutschland hat sich bewusst für
viele Abhängigkeiten von den USA
entschieden und beide Länder haben lange
vom freundschaftlichen Verhältnis
profitiert die USA haben jahrzehntelang
vor allem Sicherheit und Stabilität
versprochen in den letzten Jahren ist
genau diese Stabilität aber ins Wanken
geraten und Deutschland und Europa
müssen sich jetzt überlegen wie sie
damit umgehen wollen kategorischer
Antiamerikanismus oder das reflexhafte
auf die USA zeigen wenn z.B Russland
kritisiert wird sind dabei aber wenig
hilfreich wie seht ihr das denn was wäre
denn für euch das ideale Verhältnis zu
den USA schreibt uns mal in die
Kommentare und übrigens wenn ihr mehr
von unserem background Check sehen wollt
dann abon er den Kanal hier kommen jetzt
öfter neue Analysen von
uns